[Musique]
marie-pierre à de nouveaux voisins
mais une mauvaise surprise arrive en
même temps que une lettre du notaire qui
la visent d'un problème lequel sur le
côté de la maison de marie pierre il y a
quatre fenêtres elles sont trop proches
de la ligne qui sépare son terrain de
celui de ses nouveaux voisins selon les
règles du code civil
les voisins pourraient exiger que
marie-pierre installe des fenêtres givré
mais le notaire a résolu le problème
les voisins consentent à ce qu'elle
conserve sa vue et il peut officialiser
le tout en préparant une servitude de
vue mais cela a un prix 800 dollars et
c'est à elle de payer
par contre tous propriétaires subséquent
de la maison voisine consentira
automatiquement à la présence de ses
fenêtres marie-pierre sera donc protégé
par cette servitude de vue le fin mot de
l'histoire
une servitude ça coûte cher mais ça vous
évite bien des misères